thank you yeah so
for the fifth I worked a lot as a data
scientist more on machinery side I don't
know where I should stand on a machine
earning side to well directly solve
business cases but I over time I got
more interested in more meta things
which includes proper experimental
design but also industrialization of
machinery models and a part of that of
course is to have a proper experimental
design because you want to make a
decision based on how well you're going
to do in production environment so my
company is called Kiba dachi we are
mostly focused on industries ation but
that's not not the talk of this or the
topic of this talk so we're gonna talk a
bit about how to properly evaluate how
well your model is going to do in a
production environment or how well you
can predict something in a fair fair way
so first we're going to talk a bit about
the problem statement we're going to
talk about generalization so it's a bit
of a more theoretical topic maybe than
the other tools we're gonna talk a bit
about certain assumptions that we
usually implicitly make but that can
have a very significant impact in how
you have to evaluate your your
performance we're going to talk about a
number of different validation schemes
and the up-and-down sides of this and
why we choose certain ones and why we
even do this and then there are some
small other pitfalls that you can fall
into that will make you over or in their
estimation performance so the problem
statement is let's say we have built a
model the model has been chosen over a
number of other models its first any
type of case and we're interested in
knowing how well this mobile is going to
solve our task this is very important
because we usually have to make a
decision whether we're going to actually
use this model where we're going to
invest time and money into into using
this model or to maybe help help the
more on the research side to help help
the society further this is very
important quite a recent example where
this went terribly wrong and it's not
even read fixed it so last year a number
of researchers said they could solve
predicting earthquakes by using deep
learning
but they they had a very severe leaking
problem where where there were basically
similar training samples or the same
training samples in their training seven
in the test set and and there were very
both claims made bate based on that it
went viral and and this was published in
nature so this is a very difficult
problem and all people make this kind of
issues even nature publishes these kind
of mistakes so I'm just this is an
example of why it's important but also
that it's very cool so I'm going to
explain a little bit about what this
generalization starting from a more
academic level down to a more industrial
or pragmatic level so the more academic
academic definition is about how well
does our model adapt to new previously
unseen data drawn from the same
distribution as the one used to create
the mobile and then it goes okay how
well does our model predict on unseen
data how else are mobile going to
predict in a production environment or
maybe your manager how much value is
this model going to generate so this is
kind of the question that we're
interested in so we want to try to
simulate how we're going to actually use
this and to and that simulation is part
of or the reason of that is to see how
well we're going to do so if we use this
definition we can look at a kind of a
formula which is based on the or it's
called a generalization error and it it
basically comes down to okay we have
this this joint probability distribution
of your feature space and your target
space or your inputs and outputs and
we're kind of interested in okay we have
this mobile FM we put in our features
outcomes the output and we want to
measure how well that does over all
possible combinations so this V is a
basic your your loss function or your
metric of how what kind of mistakes
you're making but of course this is this
is not we don't know this we cannot know
this if we knew this whole probability
distribution we wouldn't need a model so
but we're very interested in is because
this shows how what we're doing so how
can we how can we do this we could
instead kind of approximate it or
bye-bye because we do have access to
sample
from its probability distribution that's
our training set or a data set so if we
if we take a number of these individual
samples we measure we have trained a
model on different data and we we
measure how well or how poorly we're
doing that is kind of an approximation
after we average it of this initial
definition so that you can see that here
this is an approximation of this with
some kind of error term which is
introduced by it by the sampling the
expected value of this error is zero
that's important and that is the case
because we we take this we take the
sample and in reality this is not zero
and that has that's because of other
issues that we'll talk about later so
what we can then do so we can split our
data set into two pieces most people are
familiar with this you have a training
set and then you have a validation set
where your model sees the training set
and then we feed that the validation set
or mobile see what it predicts and then
calculate this this V this error that
were we're making and use that to base
our decisions on so I want to do a quick
fault experiment where I will show that
this validation is very good for doing
model selection so if we're going to do
a number of models and models could be
different algorithms different hyper
parameters and anything that makes a
difference and we're gonna use this
validation set to to do our mobile
selection choose which model we're going
to use which this is very good for but
that we cannot use that same set anymore
for actual
performing or model performance so go to
your managers say we're gonna make this
amount of money and I'll show you with
this fault experience I'll hopefully
show you why so let's say we have a
bunch of points and we're gonna do a
linear regression normally you would
have your training sets you fit this
line either directly using some
analytical properties or or using
gradient descent and we're gonna find
our optimal fit we're not going to do
that now what we're going to do is we're
going to just sample random coefficients
a and B and then see how well it
actually does on this kind of unseen
data so we have some metrics or the mean
squared error
disguise the Sun but let's say it's the
me and and then we're going to sample
these these lines and we're gonna see
how well we do so we have a line here a
and B and there's a certain mean squared
error so we take a number of these lines
and then we can look at our validation
data or a validation set to see what is
our actually our best performing model
so well that's clearly the second one
but the the the way these models are
generated are exactly the same right so
even though we didn't use any training
data it's the same if we have a bunch of
models that use the same training
training data they all get a certain
outcome so in this case the expected
expected error that we're making for all
these four lines before we actually draw
them is the same but we're going to use
user validation set to see which one
actually performs the best and that
basically means that now we've turned
our validation set into kind of our
training data because we we are using
feedback or from our validation set to
draw information about what what works
better and that's an important concept
and that's that's why yeah that's that's
why we actually need a test set we'll
get to that a bit later so here let's
say we have the same experiment and
we're just going to draw random models
and we're gonna see how well they've
work so we have a this is let's say our
mean squared error so the blue line is
kind of our expected mean squared error
and then so we've drawn six samples and
this is and the mobile we ends up with
if we don't look at this formula that
we've done our expected value this blue
line is kind of our I FM the one that we
are well we're interested in but the
sampling error or the way our model is
trained whatever the expected one was
the same for all these models but we
chose the last one so we we are the dis
will leads on average to the best model
depending of course on average most of
the time we're going to choose the best
model but it's not a fair evaluation
anymore we cannot use this this this
mean squared error anymore to tell our
boss like oh we're going to do this well
and that's because the way we the way we
kind of do this selections we
introduced a selection bias which means
that the expected value of this error is
negative and that means that we're kind
of over estimating how well we're going
to do and that's because we're using
this this kind of random noise in there
to do our selection so that's an issue
it's it's not an issue for well your
first purpose which is to find the best
model but it is an issue for before kind
of predicting how we're going to do in a
production environment so that's why
this concept of a test set is so we we
have a bunch of different Mobile's we
have we split this data in the training
set validation set and as you can see
here it's not really unseen anymore
right basically if we if we see this
whole model selection part as finding
the best solution then we're actually
seeing this data because we're but in a
more indirect way so if we do this we
check what is the best validation score
that's going to be the model that we
select and then we haven't seen actual
and seen test set that we're using for
for performing like what we're going to
yeah how well we're going to be doing
and and expect an error of that one is
zero again so that's that's kind of what
we want we want an unbiased estimate of
how well we're going to do so the the
problem of splitting our data in three
pieces is that well all of a sudden we
have a lot less data right like and
that's okay maybe if you're if you're
working with hundreds of millions of
rows but if you have say ten thousand
rows all of a sudden it becomes a big
impact in in in your data because yeah
all of a sudden you have less and
sometimes people ask okay what how big
should my validation said or how big
should my test be well that's really
about what what is your goal so there's
a kind of a trade-off there your your
training set should be as large as
possible because in the end we're gonna
train our model on all our data so the
larger the training set during your
validation step is the closer it is to
to your real case but your validation
set if it's smaller you're gonna have a
larger variance in your estimate and
that means you're more likely to choose
the wrong model that's the same with the
test set the although you're not using
it for model selection you're using it
to explain to your manager how well
you're going to be doing so if that one
is too small
there's going to be like a larger range
of what the actual values so one way to
kind of solve this issue is by using
something that most people are familiar
with it's called k-fold cross-validation
where we're basically splitting our in
this case what we had before the
training validation set we're gonna
split it in the number of folds and then
we're going to train every model that we
want to like want to be able to choose
we're gonna train it five times each
time on 80% of our data and validate
them on the other one so there's kind of
a trade-off there we're using more more
data for we're using more data so that's
good because we have better estimates or
lower variance but we also have to train
the same model five times which is going
to be more compute-intensive
and then after we've done this for a
number of models or a number of
considerations in the end we choose the
best one and use that for for our test
performance there's you can go even
further with this and that's where
because we still have this test set that
we're not actually using and that's
that's safe that's nice that's what we
want we don't want to use our test set
to do any model selection because that
defeats the purpose so there's a but if
you still want to have access to all
your data your you can do it this
concept close nest nest cross-validation
and this is this is even more extreme so
with this this first iteration looks
very similar to what we had before
we're gonna do cross-validation on our
training sets using all different models
that we were interested in choose the
best one and then see how well it does
on the on the test set then we're going
to have not a new fall to next fold with
the test set somewhere else
and we do that so that this way we can
use all our data and it's our data is
useful for all these three purposes but
a really big thing here is we are not
allowed to look at the test set to see
which model we're going to use right so
that's because that's that's our sin
that's the thing that we're trying to
prevent so how can we do this then well
we're going to look at this at at these
hyper parameters or this cross
validation we pick the model the perform
is four point five and then we're gonna
do the same thing for the next one but
if a different
mobile comes out that's okay we're not
interested in directly in our model
performs because our mobile is basically
our our whole set of possible models
that were considering so we're just
gonna use we're going to evaluate how
our model selection will what it will
lead to so in this case there might be a
different model that we choose that's
fine we're going we're then going to use
that one and then take the last one and
that one might be mobile again and then
that means that on average our selection
algorithm or the way that we select our
model and we'll end up on average
unbiased with a with an error of 3.5
whatever it is you're interested in so
now I want to talk about an assumption
that is very common or actually kind of
requires a machine learning that that
everybody's implicitly or explicitly
aware of which is called iid it's a very
common statistical thing and and it's
very important because you're trying to
estimate and button and biased fashion
how while you're doing that means you
you kind of need this so what is it what
does it mean it doesn't mean that your X
or Y or your features need to be
independent or uncorrelated or whatever
it also doesn't mean that your features
and your target should be uncorrelated
if that's the case you don't need to do
the machinery because there's nothing to
learn right so what it what it does say
it's about individual samples of your of
your of your data and that the identical
part means that every row should be from
the same distribution so it's that's
kind of a an assumption that it doesn't
hold true very very frequently and the
independently part talks about if you
know about a certain row that doesn't
give you any additional information
about the other row so there it doesn't
influence each other yeah those are the
kind of properties for that so this is
important for for a few reasons that
we'll go over now because you have these
validation schemes so this k-fold
cross-validation for example where where
we actually
sample data throughout throughout your
whole timeline so and time is often a
common reason why this iid property is
not valid because over time some
properties might change the world is
changing right that could be anything
the customer behavior if you're doing
computer vision maybe and you have 10
years of data over time cameras are
becoming better so they're more sharp or
there's all kinds of ways how over time
your data either your inputs your
outputs are changing so this kind of
drifts are yeah that that that those
violators IID assumptions but that's ok
we need to deal with it we cannot we
cannot help that but being conscious
about it can help you figure out maybe
there's a better or more fair way to
evaluate these things so the problem
here is that if we look here and we have
this k-fold cross-validation where the
where the we have the third fold is a
validation set now we're kind of
interpolating in our data set right we
have we have them if you look at it from
a like simulation perspective in the
past we have data in the future we have
data and we're trying to say something
about things in between and that's not
fair because we if we're going to use
this in the future that we can always
only look at data from the future and
then we kind of have the extrapolate so
this is maybe not a fair way to do this
kind of simulation or estimate so we
kind of if that if we believe that's an
important thing
then we should only look forward we
should only lose use actual historical
data and look forward so another way of
doing kind of a validation scheme that
takes that into account it's called the
kind of a like a time windowing approach
so there you kind of still have these
faults we still want to have this
property where we can use a lot of our
data for validation and but we just have
these faults and we only take the data
that's before that yeah so there's a
plenty of packages available think
Aleksandra worked on one a while back
that there's there's a lot of people
that have built these kind of validation
schemes and they're very important
because these kind of things can can
help you prevent making mistakes in and
how you think your
but in that sense there's kind of
because of this iid assumption that is
broken there's kind of a trade of
usually where on the one hand you always
want more data right the more data you
have the better you can learn complex
relationships the deeper networks you
can use the deeper random forest you can
use and yeah but on the other hand if
the world is slowly changing there's a
certain moment where data is so far away
from your current status that that
adding that data is actually going to
make your model perform worse so and
that's that's kind of a there's kind of
a trade-off in between finding this kind
of optimal thresholds okay we're going
to look this far back and and everything
before that is going to be discarded and
you should consider this to be a hyper
parameter of your of your model of your
approach where you can just say okay
we'll use two years of data maximum and
everything before that this is discarded
so that's said that's a thing that you
have to evaluate how well that works
with that and that also influences this
this validation scheme because all of a
sudden you're you're [ __ ] you're more
it's more like a sliding window of your
data another bias and this is one most
of the talks about overly optimistic
estimating your performance but one that
you're usually under estimating your
performance is by having a training size
bias but of course what we're doing is
we're trying to estimate how well we're
going to do in a production environment
or how are we going to do in the real
world
but but after after we've established
that we're going to train our data or
model on all of our data that means if
every time we're taking away a bit of
the data we don't train on the same size
as the real mobile so there's a in that
sense there's kind of a bias because
you're gonna have more data available so
one way to kind of be able to say
something about it although it's not as
rigorous as a lot of other things is
where you can look at okay what if we
increase our trainings training size
like how does that kind of our
performance go if we keep growing our
data size and that allows you to say a
little bit more about okay if we then go
from 80% to 100% how well does that do
another approach if you if you do think
there's this kind of maybe like the
concept drift over time the data is
changing you can also just if you only
want two years of data you can just
shift everything forward and then
there's no no problem in that regard in
another case if it is still growing
there's probably you're going to do
better than you perform but if it's if
it's already flatlining because there's
a lot of diminishing returns then then
there's a big difference in those two
there are some some more common issues
that are related to this iid assumption
one one one is that this pretty cool -
duplicate records in your data that's
not necessarily problem it could be
there's a lot of processes that actually
do generates like separate events that
have exactly the same representation and
and and if that's the case then that's
not a problem but what is a problem if
it's because of error from whatever IT
system that you're using or same sensor
issues because then all of a sudden if
it's if it's representing exactly the
same thing then if you are going to use
random splits you're gonna have the same
sample in your training set and in your
test set and then that's kind of like
you're evaluating part of your training
set so if this is a frequent error and
this is part of your exploratory data
and as plus understanding the basically
the data generation parts of what kind
of process is generating this data that
can help you kind of figure out whether
you need to deduplicate your data or if
it's if it's if it's true then you
shouldn't duplicate right you're trying
to get us close to the real rules
another another issue is a concept
called target leakage this is there's a
lot of very very direct ways where this
can go wrong but also the the more
dangerous ones are the implicit ones so
there's a let's say we have a small data
set and we're doing some kind of feature
engineering but we have to split our
features from our targets right so this
is one that I've common commonly done
it's fortunately one that's very easy to
see once you find your mobile and you're
evaluating how well you're doing
because you're gonna you're gonna have
no error well because what happens we
forgot to remove the target column from
from our training set and well this
should give you a lot of alarm bells if
you get a if you get 100% accuracy then
then there's clearly something wrong but
there's a lot of more very very more
subtle ways to do that one but this one
is only applicable for larger data sets
where you have for example categorical
value or categorical column that has a
lot of high cardinality and which which
can be difficult right you need to
represent that in a kind of a numerical
fashion for some algorithms and if you
need to have one whole tank code if you
type 150,000 different values you can
take or that can be an issue so one way
of doing that is kind of using a type of
categorical encoding thing and one of
them is where you try to describe okay
this value of this category has this
this kind of targets attached to it and
this one is pretty common it works quite
well but it's very it's a very tricky
issue with this approach is where you're
if you if you look at this so we're
going to say okay category B on average
has one is a target category a on
average has half as a target that's
correct but if we're looking at a more
how we're going to actually use this
then we don't know what the target is
right so by by doing this we're kind of
in a very like subtle way leaking
information about the target that's
corresponding to this row into into this
encoding of this category which is going
to mean that the model will we'll pick
this up and and all of a sudden your
targets or your your training data how
you process this is not from the same
distribution anymore that's what it's
going to be like in a in a live
environment so what it should be is that
you look at all the other category A's
except for your current one because
that's how you're going to also encode
them when you're doing it in a live live
environment okay so there's a few
takeaways one more thing I want to
actually say about the league
it's one way to because this is usually
happening in kind of more complex
pre-processing pipelines so one one
thing that is highly recommended for
this is to use actual things like
scikit-learn pipelines which only get to
see your your training set and doesn't
get to see the validation or the test
set yet although that sometimes not so
easy to accomplish and one cool trick to
see whether that's actually happening in
your pipeline is to to after you have
your your set you just shuffle all the
targets at random because then there's
no signal left anymore right so then if
you say if you have to do I don't do
classification you get an accuracy
that's let's say it's balanced and your
accuracy is all of a sudden it's 55%
over a large sample there's probably
something wrong that shouldn't be the
case your model shouldn't be able to
learn anything because it's random so
that could be that that's kind of a good
way to kind of see if something like
that is happening and that these kind of
things happen with these kind of
categorical encoders but also with we've
kind of more time series based things
where you're using lag features that it
could easily happen that you
accidentally somehow include some
information about the current target
yeah so take taking take away you should
really see cross validation or what kind
of estimation you're doing as a way to
simulate real life you're interested
your goal with validation is to find the
best model and with test set it's really
about estimating how well are we going
to do in real life so keep that in mind
I think that's a lot of people to do
these kind of things but really
understanding why can help you think
about reason about your your real
scenario better and and try to can help
you kind of stop making some of these
mistakes and they happen fairly
frequently so that's so think about the
kind of assumptions that you're making
think about how is your data generated
so that that's important both for how to
model your case but also to think about
how is it going to be used later and
that sends also data availability so
that's already kind of
way to this target leakage is one way
that yeah we you don't have that
available but there's a lot of other
ways and it's also broader than this
this topic thinking about when is your
data available can really help you model
things better and always keep the goal
in mind because that that is really what
it's all about right if we're trying to
solve this problem we have this goal in
mind and we need to really properly
fairly evaluate how well we can reach
that goal so that is my presentation I
want to thank you for for your time and
you can find me here on the LinkedIn or
send me e-mail
[Applause]